wer auch immer versucht uns zu stoppen
und unser land und unser volk weiter zu
bedrohen sollte wissen dass die antwort
russlands sofort erfolgen und zu
konsequenzen führen wird die sie in
ihrer geschichte noch nie erlebt haben
durch solche drohungen wachsen bei
vielen die sorgen auch in deutschland
die ängste im schul zu spätestens seit
dem russischen angriff auf die ukraine
sind lebensmittelknappheit und ein
längerer stromausfall durch
cyber-attacken reale bedrohungsszenarien
ein langanhaltender flächendeckender
stromausfall würde dazu führen dass alle
teilbereiche der gesellschaft
wir machen uns auf die spur wollen
wissen wie es deutschland auf ernstfälle
vorbereitet haben wir überhaupt noch
funktionierende punkte
reichen die staatlichen
lebensmittelvorräte gibt es krisenpläne
natürlich gibt es für solche fälle
katastrophenschutzpläne dafür sind wir
in deutschland auch vorbereitet doch
funktionieren die pläne auch in der
praxis also richtig vertrauen würde ich
nicht darauf dass so ein dokument nur
weil es plant vorhanden ist dann auch
tatsächlich praktisch gelebt wird
ich gehe spuren im netz nach und
rekonstruiere entscheidende momente der
vergangenheit
wie ist deutschland beim
bevölkerungsschutz aufgestellt und wie
kam es dazu
ich schaue vor ort nach und treffe die
entscheidung wie gut dass deutschland
für den ernstfall gerüstet nur mit
improvisationen gute willen aller
beteiligten wird man große krise nicht
berührt sind wir in deutschland auch
mögliche krisenszenarien vorbereitet tut
der staat genug um uns zu schützen
[Musik]
ich bin unterwegs in brandenburg zu
einem der schon vor dem krieg in der
ukraine selbst für alle fälle gerüstet
sein wollte wie das möchte er uns zeigen
bedingung für den dreh wir sollen weder
sein wohnort noch seinen nachnamen
nennen stephan h zeigt uns seinen
persönlichen schutzraum
das ist jetzt ihr raum
2017 hat er die garage zu einem privaten
bunker umrüsten lassen hier sammelte er
auch notvorräte
sie schätzen naturkatastrophe blackout
das war so die ursprüngliche zielsetzung
also irgendwie schon so dass man
natürlich ein erhöhtes
sicherheitsbedürfnis vielleicht auch
selber hat aber halt eben jetzt ist er
aktueller denn je hat auch das ist eben
durchaus auch für den nicht nur
katastrophe auf den kriegsfall halten
nutzbar ist ein explosionsschutz ventil
in der wand soll ihn davor schützen dass
die wände einstürzen
außerdem ist er mit einem abc schutz
filter ausgestattet
mit dem kann man halt alles biologisch
atomare stäubchen rausfiltern aus der
luft also das funktioniert ganz gut und
mal eine handkurbel betrieb kann man das
halt doch dann mechanisch mit
luftversorgung das kriegt jetzt eine
andere dimension mit der ukraine krieg
oder ja das war früher sind belächelt
worden mittlerweile ist man da jetzt
sehr froh dass man da schon ein bischen
vorgedacht hat der arzt möchte mit
seiner frau im ernstfall wenigstens eine
woche durchhalten können sein vertrauen
in den staat sei begrenzt an den wänden
bilder von kaiser wilhelm und che
guevara
es fällt mir schwer ihn einzufangen
jetzt will er seinen bunker noch weiter
robusten
deshalb kommt mark schmiechen von
deutschlands einziger firma für bunker
bauten
seit in der ukraine krieg herrscht sei
die nachfrage und der verkauf von
privaten bunkern extrem gestiegen
normale zeiten bei uns bevor dieser
krieg begonnen hat war dass wir auf
unserer internetseite um die 100
zugriffe gehabt haben dass pro tag
vielleicht zehn leute mal angerufen
haben und sich erkundigt haben mit
beginn des krieges ist das immens nach
rom wo schnell wir haben über 10.000 zu
kommen pro tag auf unserer internetseite
jetzt erklären sie sich das angst ganz
nackte angst
und diese angst greift inzwischen immer
weiter um sich
nicht nur unter den sogenannten crackern
die eigene vorbereitungen treffen um
fragen zur folge hat ein großteil der
bevölkerung angst dass sich der krieg in
europa noch ausweiten könnte
mit dem russischen angriffskrieg haben
die google suche nach atomschutzbunker
einen rekordstand erreicht
auf kleinanzeigen portalen explodieren
die anfragen nach privat bunkern
[Musik]
suche bunker
im ernstfall mieten in nrw und ganz
deutschland die angst ist groß ich bin
in kontakt mit einer userin die auch
nach hamburg versucht
was ihr schreibt das finde ich schon
krass ich sehe einen umfassenden europa
verwüsteten krieg als sicher
ihre user name ist trainer sie will mit
mir telefonieren aber unerkannt bleiben
die 24 jährige lebt in baden württemberg
und hat sich viel informiert sie sieht
sich als linksliberal ist für
waffenlieferungen an die ukraine die
aktuelle situation macht ihr große
sorgen
was macht ihnen angst
politische situation und um die ukraine
da diese last nicht auf eine
konfrontation da tourismusland rausläuft
und ist mir kein szenario vorstellen
kann den geist die konfrontation nicht
lokal in der regel endet und glauben sie
dass ab jetzt zu uns nach deutschland
auch
die russische propaganda ist schon sehr
sehr eindeutig dass die ukraine nicht
wirklich das was
china beschreibt ist der worst case ein
militärischer angriff auf deutschland
ein atomkrieg das gespräch mit ihr und
der besuch in stefan haas bunker werfen
für uns viele fragen auf
ich finde das sollte sich jetzt nach
privaten banken erkundigen ich frag mich
was macht der staat kann der starten die
schützen ja das frage ich mich halt auch
also selbst wenn es diese bunker noch
gibt in welchem zustand sind hier
eigentlich
das will ich in berlin heraus finden
denn am ende geht es darum wie schnell
solche bunkeranlagen reaktiviert werden
unter dieser kreuzung im wedding
befindet sich ein öffentlicher
luftschutzraum nur wer genau hinschaut
sieht die lüftungsanlagen und die
einstiegs klappen über der erde
im u-bahnhof pankstraße ganz am ende der
gleise empfängt mich keine von den
berliner unter werden der verein
erforscht unterirdische bauwerk in der
hauptstadt und bietet führungen an
3300 menschen sollten hier vor einem
atomaren schlag geschützt werden
gebaut fertiggestellt 1977 ist aber nie
eingesetzt werden der kalte krieg ist ja
für uns zum glück alle kalt geblieben
das heißt ihre funktion als schutzraum
in dieser zeit ist nicht erfüllt worden
und deshalb ist die anlage halt
dinge die mit zeit
noch bis in die 80er jahre hinein waren
schutzräume wie dieser einsatz bereit
denn die gefahr einer militärischen
auseinandersetzung mit der sowjetunion
war zum greifen nah
dann ein wendepunkt in der geschichte
ost und west nähern sich an
1987 michael gorbatschow und ronald
reagan unterzeichnen in washington einen
vertrag zur abrüstung
zum ersten mal in der geschichte wird
rüstungskontrolle durch rüstung ersetzt
[Musik]
1989 die berliner mauer fällt
1990 dann die wiedervereinigung der
kalte krieg ist vorbei
die gefahr eines atomkriegs scheint mit
diesem historischen ereignis für viele
für immer vom tisch zu sein
die veränderte politische lage hatte
auch auswirkungen auf den schutzraum
u-bahnhof frank straße er wird seitdem
nur noch als museum genutzt
keine führt mich in einen raum der
gerade mal 25 quadratmeter groß ist im
ernstfall sollten hier 56 menschen
reiben ich habe ein mulmiges gefühl hier
unten es riecht nach abgestandener luft
und alles hier ist in die jahre gekommen
das ganze ist auch schon ein bisschen
angestaubt wie man sieht an den fingern
sieht man es
schon ein bisschen älter die ganze
anlage
jahrhundert führt mich weiter in den
technikraum auch hier ist schnell klar
im fall eines angriffs ist der
schutzraum nicht mehr zu gebrauchen hier
erkennt man ganz gut dass es alles
eingemottet ist das hätte jetzt
im september 95 hätte die letzte wartung
sein müssen seitdem ist nichts mehr
passiert die lüftungsanlage ist das
letzte mal 2002 gewartet worden
ließe sich diese anlage überhaupt mal
eben schnell wieder reaktivieren anlagen
wie diese hier zum beispiel würden in
der wiederherstellung oder in der
wiedernutzbarmachung als schutzraum
durchaus einiges an investitionen
erfordern am ende der führung ist mir
klar diesen schutzraum zu reaktivieren
wäre extrem teuer und würde monate
dauern kurzfristig sind bunker wie diese
als öffentliche schutzräume nicht
nutzbar
so sieht es in ganz deutschland aus
heute gibt es für den zivilschutz nur
noch 599 öffentliche bunker vor 15
jahren waren es noch 2000 doch auch die
die noch da sind wurden schon jahrzehnte
nicht mehr gewartet und sind schlicht
nicht mehr einsatzfähig wie kam es dazu
ab den 90ern werden bunker im westen
nach und nach aus der zivilschutz
bindung entlassen bunker wie dieser aus
der ehemaligen ddr gar nicht erst in
schutzkonzepte aufgenommen
2007 entscheiden bund und länder dann
ihr schutzraum konzept komplett
aufzugeben bunker seien nicht mehr
zeitgemäß findet man damals das
bundesamt für immobilienaufgaben soll
viele der bauten verkaufen was aber
geschieht mit den ausgemusterten punkte
an bei der recherche hilft mir dieses
tool mit diesem internet archiv da kann
ich ins internet der vergangenheit
reisen das heißt ich kann schauen wie
sagen diese websites damals aus und was
ist aus diesen schutzbauten aus den
bunkern geworden ich schaue nach auf
alten seiten der bundesanstalt für
immobilienaufgaben wo angepriesen wurde
wie sich bunker noch nutzen lassen
hier zb dass es von 2007 schutzbauten in
kiel und energie werden für fledermäuse
umgebracht
ein anderes projekt beispiel aus
düsseldorf luxus im bogen mit rheinblick
und dabei das eigene auto per auto
aufzug auf der eigenen terrasse parken
krass und ein projekt in bochum die
nachfrage war riesig
verkauft verkauft verkauft alle verkauft
von diesen bunker wohnungen erst vor
kurzem seit dem krieg in der ukraine
wurde der verkauf von öffentlichen
bunkern gestoppt das
bundesinnenministerium hat jetzt
angesichts der ukraine kriegs erklärt
dass man das aktuelle rückbau konzept
für schutzräume prüft
aber selbst wenn die verbliebenen 599
punkte wieder einsatzbereit werden sie
böten gerade mal platz für 488 tausend
menschen das ist weniger als die
einwohnerzahl von duisburg nur ein
bruchteil der bevölkerung wäre also
aktuell noch in den vorhandenen anlagen
geschützt
der schutz der bevölkerung das ist
aufgabe des bundesamts für
bevölkerungsschutz und katastrophenhilfe
bbk
in der bonner behörde treffe ich wolfram
geyer er arbeitet hier schon seit der
gründung 2004 heute leitet er die
abteilung risikomanagement
sein job ist es mögliche
bedrohungsszenarien
auszuarbeiten und die politik zu wahren
es sind die szenarien eben zum beispiel
der große flächendeckenden stromausfall
es sind die szenarien freisetzung von
chemischen biologischen radioaktiven und
nuklearen stoffen aktuell beschäftigen
ihnen mögliche auswirkungen des ukraine
kriegs ist deutschland für den ernstfall
gerüstet also für einen klassischen
kriegsfall logischerweise können wir gar
nicht momentan ganz aktuell gerüstet
sein denn wenn jahrzehntelang abbau
betrieben worden ist von strukturen dann
kann das nicht innerhalb von tagen oder
wochen wiederhergestellt sein welch
schweren stand das bundesamt und seine
vorläufer schon immer hatten zeigt der
blick in die geschichte
1999 beschließt die rot grüne
bundesregierung das bundesamt für
zivilschutz wie die behörde damals heißt
aufzulösen hintergrund sparmaßnahmen
[Musik]
doch dann anschlag auf das world trade
center am 11 september 2001
[Musik]
2002 hochwasser an elbe und donau mit
chaotischen krisen management
[Musik]
spd innenminister otto schily nimmt die
entscheidung seiner regierung zurück
gründete 2004 das heutige bundesamt für
bevölkerungsschutz und katastrophenhilfe
dort das amt hat wenig kompetenzen es
ist nur für den zivilschutz zuständig
also im krieg für den katastrophenschutz
hingegen also erdbeben hochwasser und
andere naturereignisse haben die länder
den hut auf
weil auf der politischen führungsebene
kaum jemand einen krieg für
wahrscheinlich hält fristet das bbk in
den folgenden jahren ein schatten dasein
die behörde mahnt und warnt vor allen
möglichen szenarien durch die politik
leitet daraus meist kein handel
nach einer risikoanalyse muss zwingend
eine risikobewertung kommen das ist ein
politischer prozess und aus der
bewertung heraus müssen maßnahmen
beschlossen werden auch das ist ein
politischer prozess und an der stelle
glaube ich da hakt es noch doch aus
seiner sicht ist auch klar der staat
kann nicht für alle fälle vorsorgen auch
die bevölkerung selbst muss
vorbereitungen für drohende krisen
treffen die vorläufer behörde wie auch
unsere behörde wir fordern das seit
jahren seit jahrzehnten dass der bürger
sich vorsorge soll weil krise kann immer
mal kommen und wenn sie denn kommt kommt
sie meist unverhofft und dann ist es in
folgende vorsorge überhaupt betrieben zu
haben das bundesamt gibt dazu auch
empfehlungen raus
keine schutzräume und eine schutz
behörde die jahrelang herunter gespart
wurde
tut der staat wirklich genug um uns zu
schützen das will ich von martin voss
wissen deutschlands renommiertestem
katastrophenforscher die bevölkerung hat
wahrscheinlich die vorstellung jagen und
doppeltorschützen die behörden und
organisationen haben die vorstellung wir
haben durch begrenzte möglichkeiten und
kapazitäten mit denen tun wir unser
bestes das heißt es geht nie wirklich um
den schutz der gesamten bevölkerung also
ist dann bevölkerungsschutz auch so eine
art beruhigungspille naja solange man
eben damit suggeriert etwas was ist
eigentlich nicht es dann ist es eine art
beruhigungspille wenn man sagt wie es
ist wenn man's benennt und transparente
ihm darüber sprechen und das und das
haben wir und zwar haben wir das weil
das volk das so gewollt hat und nichts
anderes angefordert hat aber diese
debatte haben wir doch nie geführt oder
rechtlich genau diese debatte viel
vollends und das finde ich tatsächlich
äußerst bemerken ist bedenkenswert weil
es eben in letzter konsequenz
tatsächlicher um den schutz der
bevölkerung geht also um unsere existenz
gibt es dinge die die bevölkerung zu
sehr verunsichern würden dass man lieber
nicht darüber sprechen mit informationen
löst man in der regel im keine panik aus
solange eine gesellschaft in sich
solidarisch ist wo man sie eigentlich
miteinander gut klar kommt dann trägt
das auch in eine krise noch hinein oder
sagen wir das dann meint das vertrage
die bevölkerung nicht denn wäre
umkehrschluss ja wir politiker wir
machen das schon aber das sehe ich ja
eben auch nicht
martin voss macht mir klar dass die
regierung sich zwar auf manche krisen
szenarien einstellen doch viele dieser
papiere seien geheim gerade jetzt
hielten sich behörden und ministerien
bedeckt
ein papier des innenministeriums führt
in verschiedenen berichten immer wieder
erwähnt referenzszenario bund darin
werden mögliche ereignisse beschrieben
deren gefahren und auswirkungen
doch selbst abgeordnete aus dem
innenausschuss des bundestags mit denen
wir sprechen kennen den genauen inhalt
des papiers nicht ich frage das
bundesinnenministerium nach dem inhalt
des papiers
die szenarien sind als verschlusssachen
eingestuft und können daher nicht zur
verfügung gestellt werden
warum wird über diese szenarien nicht
offen geredet und wie es deutschland für
den ernstfall gerüstet das will ich
wissen und nehme die fragen mit zum
interview mit bundesinnenministerium
nancy faeser warum ist es nicht so dass
man da der öffentlichkeit reinen wein
einschenkt ich finde man muss aufpassen
wo löst man eigentlich panik aus und
macht das unnötig weil im moment haben
wir keine krisenszenarien wo wir sagen
das ist jetzt zwingend notwendig davor
zu wahren die menschen machen sich
ohnehin sorgen dieser tage und da muss
man immer genau abwägen wenn man eine
verantwortung ist was kann man zumuten
und was ist auch sinnvoll aber gewisse
krisen szenarien durchspielen macht aus
ihrer sicht keinen sinn oder zumindest
nicht den sinn dass mit der breiten
bevölkerung zu
es macht sinn diese krisenszenarien auch
anzusprechen aber angst machen macht
keinen sinn doch obwohl ihre ampel
regierungen sich transparenz auf die
fahnen geschrieben hat das papier zu den
szenarien bleibt gern was wenn
deutschland tatsächlich ziel eines
russischen angriffs werden würde also
das wollen wir natürlich alle nicht
hoffen und wir haben ja auch keine
konkreten anhaltspunkte dafür dass
erstmal die gute nachricht natürlich
gibt es für solche fälle
katastrophenschutzpläne und dann gibts
auch gemeinsame krisenstäbe die dann
eingerichtet werden dafür sind wir in
deutschland auch vorbereitet aber davon
gehen wir erstmal nicht aus die
strategie der ministerin so scheint es
zuversicht und beschwichtigen
eine öffentliche debatte über drohende
krisen szenarien vermeidet sie denn
damit sind schon minister vor ihm auf
die nase gefallen
[Musik]
2014 die russische annexion der krim ist
eine art warnschuss und auch die
bundesregierung erarbeitet pläne gegen
mögliche russische aggressionen
2016 stellt der damalige
bundesinnenminister thomas de maizière
ein neues gesamtkonzept für die zivile
verteidigung vor die pläne sehen auch
vor dass sich die bevölkerung mit
lebensmittelvorräten für den ernstfall
wappnen soll
es ist für verantwortungsvolle und
vorausschauende politik vernünftig
angemessen und mit kühlem kopf sich auf
katastrophen szenarien vorzubereiten sei
deren eintritt auch noch so
unwahrscheinlich aber
verstanden wurde das damals als aufruf
zum hamster kauf thomas de maizière
wurde als angstmacher kritisiert
müssen wir jetzt wirklich essen hamstern
opposition kritisiert zivilschutz
konzept der bundesregierung
so lacht das netz über die hamsterkäufe
[Musik]
warum kam die botschaft dass es wichtig
ist vorräte anzulegen so schlecht an ich
will darüber mit dem damaligen
innenminister thomas de maizière reden
das war einer der größten shitstorm
szene hatte und wahlkämpfer kam und
sagen soll dass lassen weil es die
bevölkerung verunsichert es hieß was
soll der quatsch mit den hamsterkäufen
unter
andrem war weit weg war gedanklich weit
weg es gab kein blutvergießen
und deswegen haben viele gesagt dass
etwas uns ja nicht geschehen das hat
mich natürlich nicht noch ermutigt auf
dem weg weiter zu beschreiten
wir haben es dann vertraulicher gemacht
vertraulicher nach dem de maizière mit
der konzeption zivile verteidigung einen
shitstorm bekam vermied er also weitere
öffentliche debatten verlagert sich die
diskussion in die hinterzimmer
auf welche szenarien hat sich
deutschland in seiner zeit eingestellt
[Musik]
man kann nicht alles auf den tisch legen
aber wir müssen dort offene werden ich
halte einen großen stromausfall wodurch
auch immer herbeigeführt für ein sehr
wahrscheinliches szenario einer großen
bedrohung und ein stromausfall meine ich
habe es nicht einige minuten so dann
wirklich mal tage da werden natürlich
einen stromausfall in dresden und er war
zwei stunden das war sehr lang für
deutsche verhältnisse
und dann fingen wir schon an darüber
nachzudenken was ein mit unseren
vorräten in der tiefe tor die vorrats
liste für die er damals so scharf
kritisiert wurde ist jetzt nach
kriegsbeginn in der ukraine wieder
aktuell der inhalt ist gleich geblieben
aber
zugegeben ich hätte nicht so viele
vorräte im schrank du machst du das also
ich habe direkt um die ecke im
supermarkt und ich kauf mir glaube ich
irgendwie wenn das drama in der woche
ein also vorräte ist bei mir echt
ist nicht gut aus die empfehlung lautet
aber jeder haushalt sollen notreserven
für zehn tage haben unter anderem 20
liter getränke pro person außerdem
mehrere kilo gemüse hülsenfrüchte obst
und milchprodukte
was wenn es tatsächlich keine
lebensmittel mehr in die läden gibt zum
beispiel bei lieferketten wegbrechen bei
einem stromausfall oder einer
naturkatastrophe
kann man sich dann darauf verlassen dass
auch der staat vorräte angelegt hat
das sind die lager in denen der bund
notfallvorräte angelegt hat 150 gibt's
davon deutschlandweit wie viel wird hier
gelagert wie viele menschen könnten
damit im zweifel ernährt werden und wie
lange
mehrfach fragen wir an ob wir dort
drehen dürfen doch seit beginn des
ukraine kriegs sind keine
medienvertreter mehr zugelassen man
lässt uns da nicht drehen man hat angst
vor plünderungen deswegen haben wir
leider nur diese videoaufnahmen
hierfür ist das
landwirtschaftsministerium zuständig das
teilt uns mit dass in der sogenannten
bundes reserve getreide rund 700.000
tonnen weizen roggen und hafer liegen
dazu kommen insgesamt
125.000 tonnen reis erbsen linsen und
kondensmilch
doch wie lange können damit
versorgungsengpässe gepuffert werden
das ministerium bleibt vage spricht von
wenigen tagen bis zu mehreren wochen je
nach szenario wie die berechnungen zu
stande kommen dazu keine info und unklar
ist auch wie verteilung verarbeitung und
zubereitung in der praxis liefen das
ministerium will jetzt ein gutachten in
auftrag geben um für eine eventuelle
lebensmittelkrise gerüstet zu sein
vorbereitet sein für den ernstfall
immerhin gibt es schon seit fast 20
jahren regelmäßige gemeinsame übungen
von bund und ländern sie haben schon
verschiedene situationen durchgespielt
mit einsatzkräften freiwilligen opfer
darstellern vor allem aber mit mails
telefonaten und krisen besprechungen
zwischen den behörden
zb 2007 eine pandemie
2011 einen cyber angriff
und 2018 eine gasmenge lager
klingt vorausschauend und sinnvoll doch
was nützen diese übungen in einer
tatsächlichen krisensituationen von
martin voss will ich wissen was behörden
und ministerien daraus lernen
wollen jetzt auch die schlüsse gezogen
wenn russland jetzt das gas zum beispiel
stoppen würde also ideal wäre natürlich
man hat danach ein katalog und männer
hat man eine checkliste alles gemacht so
läuft das natürlich nicht es werden die
schwachstellen identifiziert werden die
gehen dadurch unterschiedliche gremien
unterschiedliche diskussion das heißt es
verbessert wieder war es irgendwann
steht die finanzfrage wer soll das
bezahlen
und so bleibt natürlich am ende seines
prozesses nicht diese eine checkliste
abgearbeitet ist da wird jetzt in den
ministerien und behörden gerade auch die
arbeit an neuen szenarien laufen nämlich
an oder das ist auch nicht so dass da
immer ganz große experten gremien sitzen
und nun mal sehr dezidiert verschiedene
szenarien sich überlegen das papier
entsteht in so einem prozess vor
unterschiedliche akteure befragt werden
und auch ein andermal beraten bringt man
was zu papier und dann verschwindet das
irgendwo in den schubladen das ist die
tatsächlich die praxis das zeigt auch
der blick in die vergangenheit
beispiel 2020 corona pandemie
schon jahre zuvor gab es eine eindeutige
risikoanalyse trotzdem fehlt es an
schutzausrüstung im gleichen jahr geht
ein bundesweiter wahltag schief weil zu
viele behörden gleichzeitig waren
meldungen abgeben sind die server von
wahn apps überlastet nichts funktioniert
auch die flut im sommer 2021 im westen
deutschlands liegt mängel beim
katastrophenschutz schonungslos offen
muss immer erst etwas schlimmes
passieren bevor konkrete vorsorge
maßnahmen umgesetzt werden ich fahre
nach bad münstereifel
kurz nach der flut vor einem jahr war
ich schon mal dort
die erft hatte sich innerhalb weniger
stunden in einen reißenden fluss
verwandelt die stadt ist ein symbol für
verwüstung geworden
markus ramers ist der landrat und damit
der oberste katastrophenschützer in der
region er hatte im vergangenen sommer
erfahren wie sich der ernstfall anfühlt
warnungen funktionierten nicht von jetzt
auf gleich war der strom flächendeckend
weg dann war es einfach für uns
verheerend dass die kommunikation
abgebrochen ist funksprüche gehört da
haben einsatzkräfte mitgeteilt unter
tränen dass die bestimmte ortschaften
nicht mehr erreichen können das war pure
verzweiflung
der 35 jährige will nach der flut
strukturen schaffen um besser für den
nächsten ernstfall gerüstet zu sein
er nimmt mich mit nach euskirchen zu
seinem amtssitz
[Musik]
hier auf dem dach steht eine von vier
serien im landkreis die überhaupt noch
funktionieren
sicherlich ist die gesamte bahn
infrastruktur etwas wo wir einfach noch
mal schauen müssen an welchen stellen
müssen wir uns verbessern was braucht es
zusätzlich aber auch in welchen fällen
wird überhaupt gewarnt
was erzählt mir dass er jetzt massiv
nachrüsten will sein kreis hat beim bund
anträge für 132 neue serien gestellt
er will nie wieder so hilflos dastehen
ein neues krisenzentrum das gerade
gegenüber gebaut wird soll ihm dabei
helfen hier sollen im ernstfall alle
behörden rund um die uhr arbeiten
notfalls können die mitarbeiter hier
auch übernachten
vor allem die
kommunikationsinfrastruktur soll massiv
ausgebaut werden internet versorgung
durch satelliten doch es brauche mehr
auch die strukturen müssen neu gedacht
werden findet er
[Musik]
wir haben jetzt so ein fenster in dem
wir etwas erreichen können bevor
irgendwann vielleicht wieder so eine
katastrophen demenz einsetzt und dann
brauchen wir auch eben hier
entsprechende investitionen
hier im kreis euskirchen und in der
gesamten flutregion rüsten sie kräftig
nach in sachen bevölkerungsschutz
wir waren auf der spur haben die
schutzkonzepte analysiert und wird
entscheidung gesprochen unser fazit der
bevölkerungsschutz wurde zu lange
vernachlässigt
deutschland ist deshalb heute nicht für
große krisenszenarien gerüstet
bislang wurde immer nur reagiert doch um
auf den ernstfall wirklich vorbereitet
zu sein müssen konkrete strategien
entwickelt werden denn nur wenn wir alle
wissen was zu tun ist und was uns dafür
zur verfügung steht sind wir vorbereitet
und können mit der unsicherheit umgehen